Hey Chris.
Hey!
All right boys she made it to the party.
Let's navigate.  Phil, how does the battery juice look?
We're at 89%.  She used up some juice texting an Uber ride over.
It'll have to do.
Okay I've located 4 outlets in the living room in case she needs to charge.
She might need to use her phone if she wants to look busy or coy.
Good idea.  Who's this guy?  Is she into him?
Hey Melissa!  You made it!
Yeah.
Aw, welcome.
That's James he's a work friend.  He and Courtney just broke up.  But he's a Ginger.   Zero possibility.
Copy that.  Lets get her out of there.
How's it going?
Good good!  I'm going to get a drink.
Oh yeah.
What are we looking at boys?
We got white wine, some microbrew and tequila.
Shots?
So we're raging tonight?
It appears that way.
Shot shot shot shot shot!
Get her out of there.
No exits found.
Oh my God he looks so drunk!
Drunk levels rising.
Dive!  Dive!
Ugh!
Cute boy alert!
Oh, I'm detecting hormonal shifts.
Give me a line.
Searching.
You're not even searching, it's in sleeping mode.
Oh.
Stupid.  You stupid idiot.
You're fired.
I didn't do it.
Get me a line, Phil!
I like your big muscles.
Oh yeah.
That was awful.
I'm wasted.
Uh ma'am, actually I think he's kind of into it.
We need an emergency exit strategy.
I need to sleep.
My mouth tastes like Captain Crunch and beef jerky.
*burps*
Uh.  Ew.
Stop it Phil!  Swallow it.
Whatever.
Hey guys!  I hope you enjoyed that command center sketch.
We have a few more in the works for you.
And I wanted to let you know:
October 6th, I have a show at the Ontario Improv and it's all of my favorite Asian female comedians
and of course Brad for diversity.
And this is actually like a test show.  If it goes well
I may go on tour across the United States and possibly
even some other countries.
So if you've always wanted to see me do some stand up
come to that show or any of these shows.
I'll be doing all the jokes!
A few weeks ago I was asked to take part in JCPenney's campaign
that celebrated female empowerment.
There were so many rad women on this campaign.
They had like a computer programmer, a U.S. Air Force Officer, a fitness enthusiast, and so many more.
And they brought me on as an advocate for suicide prevention.
As you guys know, my sister committed suicide 8 years ago and
since then I've been very vocal about how we can prevent suicide
how can we combat bullying and
end all the stigmas against mental illness.
And it's hard to try to find like a comedic angle for all this stuff but
I've always been a strong believer that the best way to have people think about your message
is to have them laugh first.
So yay.  Thank you so much to JCPenney for having me on this amazing campaign.
And for letting me keep this dope outfit.
I've worn it like so many times since I brought it home.  It's really cool.
I'll put a link to the LookBook down in the description below
and of course you can get all of these fabulous outfits at JCPenney.com
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.
Give me a line!
Searching.
No give me a line now!
Give me a line!
Searching.
Give me a line right now!
I'm searching!
Hurry up!